>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN
ORDERING U.S. INTELLIGENCE TO
REDOUBLE THEIR EFFORTS TO FIND
OUT EXACTLY WHERE THE
CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM.
THAT IS AFTER HIS ADMINISTRATION
SHUT DOWN AN INVESTIGATION LED
BY FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO TO DO THE SAME
THING.
BIDEN PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT
TODAY THAT SAYS THE INTEL
COMMUNITY IS SPLIT BETWEEN TWO
LIKELY SCENARIOS ON COVID
ORIGIN, THE WUHAN LAB LEAK OR
ANIMAL TO HUMAN CONTACT, THEY
HAVE 90 DAYS TO REPORT BACK TO
THE PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICAN SENATORS ARGUE.
>> JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
NEED TO STOP THERE COVER-UP THAT
IS BENEFITING THE CHINESE
COMMUNISTS AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ONLY REASON BIDEN IS DOING
THIS, IT'S BECOMING UNTENABLE
NOT TO LOOK AT WHETHER THE VIRUS
ORIGINATED IN A CHINESE LAB.
IF THE SOURCE OF COVID-19 IS
FROM A LAB IN CHINA WE NEED TO
HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Dana: WE HERE WE ARE, I
HAVE A LITTLE LIST.
POMPEO CALLING OTHERS, REMEMBER
THEY SAY IT COMES FROM A LAB,
THEY WERE RIDICULED.
THEN POMPEO AND U.S.
INTELLIGENCE START
INVESTIGATIONS, BIDEN GETS
ELECTED, SHUTS IT DOWN, THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL BUT
ALL THAT IS HAPPENING,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" HAS A
STORY THAT IS ACTUALLY, PEOPLE
IN CHINA WENT TO THE HOSPITAL
AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE
COMING FROM A LAB AND NOW ALL OF
A SUDDEN THERE'S A NEW
INVESTIGATION.
HOW DOES THE SIT WITH YOU?
>> Jesse: YOU GET JOE'S
SCHEDULE EVERY DAY.
USUALLY ONE HALF EVENT COMES
OUT.
TODAY'S SCHEDULE COMES OUT, IT'S
NOTHING.
VERY LIGHT DAY.
SO ON A DAY THAT HE HAS NOTHING
TO DO, THE REPORT COMES OUT THAT
SAYS HE JUST KILLED THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE LAB, HE
COMES OUT AND RELEASES THIS BIG
STATEMENT AND SAYS, OH, WE ARE
GOING TO INVESTIGATE THIS LAB
THEORY AND IT WAS THE DAY AFTER
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SAID WE DIDN'T NEED TO ACTUALLY
DO THIS.
COME ON, AND NOW THE SPIN COMES
OUT THAT OH, YEAH, THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE DOING THE
INVESTIGATION FOR TRUMP, KIND OF
SLOPPY.
THE GUY DOING IT WAS A
BLOODHOUND, DANA, HE
INVESTIGATED AL QAEDA FINANCES,
HE WORKED FOR BOTH PARTIES, HE
HAD A LEGIT RESUME.
I DON'T TRUST WHATEVER THE
INTELLIGENCE TEAM IS GOING TO
PUT OUT FOR JOE BIDEN.
NO CREDIBILITY TO ME, THEY COULD
HAVE SOME GOOD PEOPLE IN THERE,
SOME PATRIOTS BUT HE HIRED A
BUNCH OF RUSSIA HOAXERS,
TRUMPETERS, CORPORATE LOBBYISTS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND HE'S RIGHT.
THE COVER-UP CONTINUES, THE
QUESTION IS, WHO ARE THEY
COVERING UP FOR?
FAUCI, CHINA AND CORPORATE
AMERICA?
HUNTER?
HAS HUNTER EVEN DIVESTED FROM
THAT INVESTMENT FUND?
I DON'T THINK HE HAS, SO WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE?
LET ME JUST PLAY SOME LOGIC
HERE, DAY NOW.
IF IT DIDN'T COME FROM A WET
MARKET, OKAY, IF IT CAME FROM A
WET MARKET THEN WHY, TWO WEEKS
AFTER THE PANDEMIC WAS UNLEASHED
TO THE WET MARKETS GO BACK UP.
WHY DO THEY STILL HAVE WET
MARKETS ALL OVER CHINA?
IF IT CAME FROM A WET MARKET
WITHIN THE CHINESE SAY, THIS IS
WHERE IT CAME FROM, WE ARE GOING
TO BAN THIS AND POINT TO THE
SPECIES THAT IT CAME FROM.
INSTEAD, WHAT THEY DID WAS THEY
SILENCED AND DISAPPEARED TO THE
SCIENTISTS, ERASED ALL THE FILES
AT THE LAB AND NOW STATE MEDIA
IN CHINA BLAMES THE U.S.
MILITARY FOR UNLEASHING IT.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE EVERYTHING
IS UNDER CONTROL?
>> Dana: THERE'S A MEDIA
ANGLE, JIM GARRITY WAS WRITING
ABOUT THE LAB LEAK POSSIBILITY
AND HE GOT ABSOLUTELY RIDICULED.
TODAY HE WRITES THIS, "YOU ALL
SET HIT THERE, WITH MY YOUTUBE
VIDEO, GOOGLE TRANSLATE VERSIONS
OF CHINESE STATE HEALTH INDUSTRY
WEB SITES AND OLD MEDICAL
RESEARCH PAPERS.
SET UP THE BUFFET TABLE BECAUSE
I WANT TO WATCH ALL OF YOU EAT A
LOT OF IT.
WILL THEY DO THAT?
>> Greg: NO THEY WON'T.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO COVER UP
ANYTHING, THEY ARE JUST TRYING
TO COVER THEIR BUTTS.
WE HAVE TO EXPRESS SOME SYMPATHY
FOR THE WET MARKET INDUSTRY,
I'VE BEEN ON THE LINE WITH THE
NATIONAL WET MARKET TRADE
ASSOCIATION AND THEY'VE BEEN HIT
PRETTY HARD BY THIS AND IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A WHILE FOR THE
WET MARKET INDUSTRY TO BOUNCE
BACK FROM THIS UNFAIR SMEAR.
THE PANGOLIN'S, THE BATS,
DELICIOUS BUT NO ONE IS EATING
THEM, DANA.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
WHATEVER TRUMP DOES, NO MATTER
IF IT'S RIGHT, WE CAN'T DO IT.
IF HE FOUND THE SOLUTION TO
AGING, CNN WOULD COME OUT IN
FAVOR OF EUTHANASIA.
THEY CANNOT BE ON THE STATESIDE
IS HIM EVEN THOUGH IT TURNS OUT
THAT GOT A PRETTY GOOD BATTING
AVERAGE IF YOU LOOK AT, PROBABLY
THE FIRST REAL, LOUDEST VOICE ON
CHINA, RIGHT?
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, THE
TRAVEL BAN, REMEMBER WHEN HE
PUSHED OPERATION WARP SPEED WE
CAN TRUST THE VACCINE SAID THE
MEDIA, SAID BIDEN, WE CAN'T
TRUST THAT BECAUSE FROM.
WHAT IS IT SOUND LIKE?
IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS.
WE CAN'T TRUST WHAT THE TRUTH IS
EVEN THOUGH IT'S THE TRUTH AND
THIS IS WHERE THE BIG PROBLEM
LIES.
EVEN IF TRUMP WAS WRONG ABOUT
SOMETHING, YOU SHOULD STILL DO
THE NEWS, YOU IDIOTS.
THESE ARE TWO SEPARATE ISSUES,
THEY ARE TWO SEPARATE ISSUES.
YOU CAN SAY "I DON'T LIKE TRUMP,
THEREFORE I DON'T TRUST HIM ON
THIS ISSUE.
BUT I SHOULD REALLY EXPLORE THE
LAB LEAK SINCE IT SEEMS TO BE
THE SIMPLEST EXPLANATION."
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO BOTH OF
THEM.
THAT'S ON THE NEWS.
>> Dana: WHY DO YOU THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALL OF A
SUDDEN ANNOUNCED TODAY A
REDOUBLING OF EFFORTS AND 90
DAYS REPORT BACK?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU SAID IT,
DANA.
WE NOW HAVE FROM INTELLIGENCE
SOURCES REPORTS ABOUT THE TWO OR
THREE PEOPLE, APPARENTLY PEOPLE
WHO WERE AT THE LAB WHO GOT
SICK, THIS IS GOING BACK INTO
MUCH EARLIER THAN WE KNEW AND
GOT SICK WITH SYMPTOMS.
WE ARE NOT SURE BUT IT COULD BE
THAT THEY GOT SICK WITH SYMPTOMS
OF COVID.
WE HAVE MORE INFORMATION FROM
PUBLIC SOURCES THAT WOULD
JUSTIFY THAT KIND OF
INVESTIGATION AND RIGHT NOW
THERE SHOULD BE, THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
AN INVESTIGATION.
THERE ARE MORE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT THIS THAN THE
KENNEDY ASSASSINATION SO WE NEED
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
YOU CAN'T TRUST CHINA IN MY
OPINION BECAUSE IT'S A
REPRESSIVE AUTHORITARIAN REGIME
WHERE THE TRUTH CAN GET YOU
KILLED.
SO I THINK THAT WE'VE GOT TO
SOMEHOW FIND A WAY TO GET THIS
DONE.
YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT POMPEO DID, I'M NOT
SURE THAT POMPEO IS THE RIGHT
GUY TO DO THIS BECAUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HANDLED PATRISSE
CULLORS SO BADLY THAT I THINK
LOTS OF PEOPLE LIKE POMPEO WOULD
GLADLY SOMEHOW LOOK AT ORIGINS
TO JUST TRY TO DISTRACT AND
CHANGE THE SUBJECT AND GET AWAY
FROM THEIR OWN RESPONSIBILITIES
SO I THINK EVEN HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE CAN'T GET TOGETHER
AND SAY LET'S HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION OF JANUARY 6TH AND
AN ATTACK ON OUR OWN CAPITAL.
IMAGINE WHAT'S GOING ON IN
CHINA.
>> Jesse: CAN I CORRECT
SOMETHING ONE SAID?
THE STATE DEPARTMENT UNDER TRUMP
IN JANUARY PUT OUT A FACT SHEET
THAT SAYS THESE GUYS GOT SICK IN
2019, THAT WAS OUT THREE MONTHS
AGO.
THAT'S NOT NEWS.
B3 THREE MONTHS.
IN OTHER WORDS, NOT ONE POMPEO
STARTED.
>> Jesse: NOT TODAY.
>> Dagen: TRUMP HANDLED THE
CORONAVIRUS EPIDEMIC BADLY?
ONE WORD ON THAT, VACCINES.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
STORIES IN MY LIFETIME INTO
QUOTE GREG GUTFELD, COMMON SENSE
IS THE ENEMY OF IDEOLOGUES,
ESPECIALLY STUPID AND LAZY
IDEOLOGUES.
AND I MEAN THE MEDIA.
SO FROM DAY ONE, PEOPLE ON FOX
BUSINESS WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
WUHAN VIROLOGY LAB WHICH WE KNEW
WAS PERFORMING RESEARCH ON
CORONAVIRUS' WHICH MEANS TO MAKE
THEM MORE DEADLY, TO RAMP UP
THEIR SPREAD.
WE KNEW THAT.
BUT WHAT WAS THE MEDIA DOING?
SIDING WITH THE COMMUNIST PARTY
OF CHINA INSTEAD OF A SITTING
U.S. SENATOR, TOM COTTON WHO WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS VIROLOGY LAB
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO SO THAT'S
WHERE THE MEDIA IS AND THEY ARE
STILL DOING IT, PETER DOOCY
ASKED JEN PSAKI ABOUT THIS VERY
ISSUE TWO DAYS AGO AND YESTERDAY
AND THAT IDIOT SITE WAS WRITING
MOCKING STORIES ABOUT
PETER DOOCY AND TODAY THE WHOLE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS IS
TRYING TO ASK JEN PSAKI ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
STORIES OF OUR LIFETIME BUT
TRUMP, BAD DICTATOR IN CHARGE,
MEANTIME THREE AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE ARE DEAD BECAUSE
OF COMMUNIST CHINA ANTIVIRUS